* Sanfte Musik *
(Deanna Panzeri:)
Als ich am 19. aufstand,
spürte ich, dass ich nicht mehr
atmete wie sonst.
(Elena Merlini:)
Es war, als ob ich unter Wasser sei,
ich bekam keine Luft.
Das war das schlimmste Erlebnis
meines Lebens.
(Roberto Gatti:)
Ich wurde intubiert,
und von da an
weiss ich nichts mehr.
Drei Menschen,
die das Virus überlebt haben.
Tagelang schwebten sie
zwischen Leben und Tod.
Jetzt sind sie
auf dem Weg zurück ins Leben.
Die Tessiner Rehaklinik Novaggio
und die Klinik Hildebrand in Brissago
helfen ihnen dabei.
Ich bekam einfach keine Luft mehr.
Das ist schwer zu beschreiben,
auch weil ich mich
an vieles nicht mehr erinnere.
Anfang März fühlte sich
Deanna Panzeri matt und fiebrig.
Sicherheitshalber
begab sie sich selber in Quarantäne.
Doch ihr Zustand
verschlechterte sich schnell.
Ein Notarzt
verschrieb ihr Medikamente,
veranlasste aber keinen Virustest.
Dann überstürzten sich
plötzlich die Ereignisse.
Ich weiss nur noch,
dass ich in die Intensivstation
des Moncucco-Spitals gebracht
und dort sediert
und intubiert wurde.
Aber ich erinnere mich an nichts.
Das alles
haben sie mir später erzählt.
Bei Roberto Gatti begann es
am Freitag, den 13. März:
starkes Unwohlsein,
Fieber, extreme Kopfschmerzen.
Sein Hausarzt überwies ihn
ins Regionalspital Mendrisio.
Der Virustest machte alles klar:
Corona-positiv.
Nur einmal habe ich
darüber nachgedacht,
was alles passieren könnte.
Das war, als sie mich mit dem
Krankenwagen ins Spital fuhren.
Da schoss es mir durch den Kopf,
dass ich meine Familie
vielleicht nie wiedersehen würde,
dass das ein Abschied für immer
sein könnte,
ohne weitere Kontakte.
Mein ganzes Leben lief wie ein Film
vor meinen Augen ab,
und dann plötzlich – ein Blitz.
Elena Merlini ist 39 und
leidet an einer Autoimmunkrankheit,
der Myasthenie, die zu einer extrem
starken Ermüdung der Muskeln führt.
Die Infektion mit dem Corona-Virus
wirkte sich verheerend aus:
Als sie
im Carità-Spital Locarno ankam,
war ihr Zustand bereits kritisch.
Ich war schon drei Tage dort,
als sich die Tür öffnete
und vier Anästhesisten hereinkamen
sowie ein Arzt mit einer Maschine.
Sie eröffneten mir,
dass sie mich intubieren müssten,
weil sie das Schlimmste
verhindern wollten.
Ich hatte keine Zeit mehr,
meinen Partner anzurufen,
ich telefonierte nur noch
mit meiner Mutter und sagte:
"Mama, sie müssen mich intubieren",
und gab das Telefon dem Arzt weiter.
Ich weiss noch,
dass ich die Ärzte anflehte,
sie sollten mich
nicht sterben lassen.
Ich habe sie wirklich angefleht.
Hatten Sie Angst?
Wahnsinnig. In meinem ganzen Leben
hatte ich noch nie solche Angst.
Ich wachte auf.
Ich fühlte mich miserabel,
die Zunge war wie aus Karton,
die Kehle völlig ausgetrocknet.
Und Durst hatte ich.
Der Durst hat mich die ganze Zeit
begleitet, sogar jetzt noch.
Aber sonst weiss ich nichts mehr.
Meine Familie
hat Höllenqualen gelitten.
Als ich wieder zu mir kam,
bat ich sie immer wieder
um Entschuldigung für das.
Innere Leere, Verwirrung,
Angst vor dem Kontrollverlust –
daran leiden die Patienten,
die 5, 10 oder gar 15 Tage
intubiert waren, noch heute.
Ein Loch in der Erinnerung.
Als ich diese Patienten
das erste Mal sah,
als sie eingeliefert wurden -
sie blickten ins Leere,
als ob sie einen Fixpunkt suchten,
als ob ihnen
noch nicht bewusst wäre,
dass sie das Schlimmste
überstanden haben.
Und in diesen ersten Tagen
hatten sie ein ganz grosses
Bedürfnis nach menschlicher Nähe.
Das hat mich am meisten beeindruckt.
- Wie geht es mit atmen?
- Gut.
- Und die Beine?
- Die Beine gut. Einfach die Maske.
Die ist mühsam?
Ich würde sagen, das Wichtigste ist
jetzt, wieder zu Kräften zu kommen,
und wieder das tun zu können,
was ich vorher konnte.
Bevor ich hierher kam,
war nur schon das Duschen,
wie Radfahrer sagen würden,
ein Anstieg auf den Mont Ventoux.
Ich brauchte etwa eine Stunde und
kam völlig kaputt aus der Dusche.
Als Covid-Patient berührt dich
niemand, niemand ist bei dir,
du musst selber klarkommen.
(Pascale Janner:)
Es gibt eine grosse Befriedigung.
Wir erleben Unbezahlbares,
wir sind privilegiert,
weil bei uns die akute Phase
vorbei ist und wir wissen,
dass diese Patienten
das Schlimmste hinter sich haben.
Das Schlimmste ist vorbei,
und wir helfen ihnen,
wieder das Gefühl zu geniessen,
wenn sie das erste Mal
Luft schnappen auf dem Balkon
oder wie beim ersten Mal Rad fahren.
In der Klinik Novaggio
werden seit einigen Wochen
Corona-Patienten betreut, die
auf Nachbehandlung angewiesen sind.
Die Physiotherapie
findet im Zimmer statt,
damit das Risiko einer allfälligen
Ansteckung anderer Patienten
oder des Personals vermindert wird.
(Nicola Schiavone:) Um die
Nicht-Covid-Patienten zu schützen,
haben wir zwei getrennte Abteilungen
eingerichtet,
und das Personal arbeitet entweder
auf der einen oder der andern.
Wir mussten genau schauen,
wie wir diese Patienten pflegen
und sie dabei weiterhin
peinlich genau isolieren können.
Das hat natürlich
unsere tägliche Arbeit beeinflusst,
weil wir getrennte Abläufe
einrichten mussten,
damit auch die Nicht-Covid-
Patienten, die sog. normalen Fälle,
in den Genuss
einer angemessenen Reha kommen,
ohne dass für sie
ein Risiko besteht.
* Sanfter Rocksong "Isolation"
von John Lennon *
# Sie sagen, wir hätten es geschafft.
# Wissen sie nicht,
dass wir Angst haben?
# Isolation.
# Wir haben Angst vor der Einsamkeit.
# Jeder braucht doch ein Zuhause.
# Isolation.
Auch in der Klinik Hildebrand
in Brissago ist eine eigene Abteilung
mit 14 Bettenplätzen
für Covid19-Patienten reserviert.
Für die verschiedenen
Krankheitsbilder
braucht es auch
spezialisiertes Personal.
(Guia Fortunani:)
Wenn ein Patient in Quarantäne kommt,
einer, der infiziert ist,
hat man zuerst Ängste,
die man kaum kontrollieren kann.
Aber mit der Zeit merkt man:
Ob es sich jetzt um einen Patienten
mit neurologischen Problemen handelt
oder um einen mit dem Virus, man
muss beide genau gleich behandeln.
Das Virus setzt nicht nur dem Körper
zu, sondern auch der Seele.
Auch diese Verletzungen
müssen behandelt werden.
Wie geht es?
Ich bin ja hier, das kann ich sagen.
Aber wenn ich an die Menschen denke,
die es nicht geschafft haben -
das prägt dich.
Es sind ja nicht nur die älteren
Leute, die es nicht geschafft haben,
sondern auch junge.
Und dann: Auch ein älterer Mensch
hätte wohl gern noch länger gelebt.
Man kann nicht einfach sagen,
weil er jetzt älter ist ...
Es zeichnet für immer
und bestimmt auch die Art,
wie man die Zukunft sieht.
- Genau.
Auch der Körper
braucht seinen Wiederaufbau.
Viele Patientinnen und Patienten
haben vom langen Liegen
ihre Kraft verloren.
Für sie wurde eigens
ein Fitnessraum eingerichtet.
Diese Reha ist für mich
wie eine Wiedergeburt.
Ich musste wieder gehen lernen.
Nach fünf Wochen im Bett
und dem ganzen Stress
für den Körper -
das war nicht leicht.
Ich habe immer noch Probleme
beim Gehen, aber das ist halt so.
Ich lerne Schritt für Schritt
treppenzusteigen.
Zum Glück bin ich noch jung
und mache schnell Fortschritte,
und auch die Physiotherapeuten
sind zufrieden.
Von mir her gesehen
funktioniert das.
Hallo Mama!
Ich bin froh, dich zu sehen.
* Schluchzen *
Wie schön, dich nach dieser
ganzen Zeit zu sehen!
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Ich habe gedacht, heute versuchen
wir mal, das Bett zu machen.
Wie geht es?
* Seufzer *
- Einfach, aber mühsam.
- Es ist anstrengend.
Der Ergotherapeut
hilft den Patienten,
ihren Alltag wieder
selbstständig zu bestreiten.
Wenn sie dann
nach Hause zurückkehren,
hilft ihnen das einerseits im Alltag
und anderseits,
ihren Körper zu trainieren
und die Kraft wiederzuerlangen,
die sie zum Leben brauchen.
(Deanna Panzeri:)
Der Aufenthalt hier in Novaggio
ist wirklich ein wichtiger Schritt,
wenn man bedenkt,
was ich alles überwinden musste.
Man muss gegen diesen ganzen
schrecklichen Mist ankämpfen.
Die Hände hinter den Nacken ...
Zusammenbringen geht nicht,
aber drücken Sie nur.
Jetzt einatmen.
Ich bin jetzt bald fertig
mit der Reha,
ich kann mich
praktisch allein bewegen.
Und seit bald einer Woche kann ich
mich am Morgen ganz allein duschen.
Versuchen Sie es nochmals,
aber mit der Ferse nach vorn,
und drücken Sie!
Wir schauen zuerst,
ob es an der Kraft fehlt
oder ob wir uns eher
um das Atmen kümmern müssen,
um die allgemeine Kondition
oder das Gleichgewicht.
Daher muss man mit den Patienten
reden, sie kennenlernen.
Man muss auch
ein Vertrauensverhältnis aufbauen.
Gemeinsam schaffen wir es,
die Therapieziele zu erreichen.
Ich schaue oft zum Fenster hinaus.
Ich liebe den Frühling
und den Sommer.
Und draussen sehe ich die Zeichen,
dass langsam meine Jahreszeit kommt.
Da ist ein Schwalbennest,
das mir unheimlich viel bedeutet.
Und ich schaue auf meinen See hinab,
und so vergeht der Tag.
Ich wohne im Dorfzentrum und
muss dort über zwei Treppen steigen.
Wenn ich hier rauskomme,
nach all den Übungen:
Was wird dann
mit den zwei Treppen sein?
Werde ich sie leicht schaffen
oder nur mit einer Pause?
Ich habe riesengrosse Lust,
heimzukehren.
Ich bin schon fast einen Monat weg.
Und dann hoffe ich,
dass ich mit der Zeit zu Hause
wieder alles tun kann wie früher.
Hallo, Schatz.
Hör mal, ich habe gute Nachrichten.
Heute Morgen habe ich die übliche
Physio mit Pascale gemacht
und mein Körper ist tierisch,
fast wie der von Luca Carboni.
Weisst du,
woran ich in letzter Zeit denke?
Dass bald, wenn sie mich freilassen,
unser Hochzeitstag kommt.
- Den feiern wir dann!
- Gut. Es werden langsam viele...
Klar. Leider!
Was leider?
Hier drin leben wir
wie in einer Blase.
Ich habe Angst vor dem,
was draussen ist.
Es ist ja nicht einfach
eine Operation, mit Reha,
und danach ist alles wieder normal.
Jetzt komme ich raus,
und nichts ist mehr wie zuvor.
Was bleibt vom Virus
in der Lunge zurück?
Die Schäden in der Lunge
scheinen gut zu verheilen,
meistens vollständig.
Daher ist es gut möglich,
dass die Lunge wieder so wird,
wie sie vor der
Corona-Infektion war.
Stimmt es, dass das Virus
auch andere Organe schädigt?
Ja, weil es die Rezeptoren,
an denen das Virus andockt
und so in den Organismus eintritt,
nicht nur in der Lunge,
sondern auch in anderen Organen
und anderem Gewebe gibt.
Das erklärt, warum es zum Beispiel
auch eher Nieren-
als Leberprobleme gibt.
Das Resultat des zweiten Abstrichs
ist gekommen,
und auch dieser ist negativ.
Jetzt haben wir zwei Abstriche
mit negativen Resultaten.
Wie schön!
Was für eine tolle Nachricht!
Es läuft gut.
Ihr Atmungsapparat erholt sich gut.
Also, das ist wirklich
eine gute Nachricht.
Danke.
Das ist wirklich toll.
Ich bin glücklich.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich glaube,
jetzt fehlt nicht mehr viel.